well we'll be speaking on the subject of
reproducibility next slide please
I want to tell you all about jumping I
need the next slide to do that there we
go
John is a professor of medicine health
service health health research and
policy and biomedical data science at
Stanford he came to international fame I
would say many years ago when he
published his provocative paper on why
the results of notice biomedical studies
are false and has continued to spend the
rest of his career helping people
understand why science is not always as
reproducible as we might think
he also while Stanford directs the ph.d
program in epidemiology and clinical
research he is co-director of a major
new initiative at Stanford called a meta
Research Innovation Center which is
looking precisely at areas of scientific
reproducibility as an endowed chair in
the center for disease prevention that
Stanford University and is someone who
at Stanford is ubiquitous and some of
whom everyone respects and really
looking forward to hearing what he has
to say this morning John this year's a
few Thank You Marc it's a great pleasure
to participate in this series and to try
to discuss the pretty convoluted topic
of reproducibility there's a lot of
confusing terminology to start with
people are talking about reproducibility
but they're also talking about
replication and then you can hear exact
replication and conceptual replication
reanalysis repeatability corroboration
triangulation all these terms have been
out there for a long time but they're
currently being revisited as we're
facing new challenges and new dilemmas
with new types of studies new types of
data and new challenges on what
reducibility means this is showing how
often the term reproducibility is used
across all domains of science there's an
exponential growth over time in the
popularity of this terminology basically
we can think of three types of
stability reproducibility of methods
reproducibility of results and
reproducibility of entrances we
participative methods the ability to
understand or repeat as exactly as
possible the experimental and
computational procedures so if you have
some software and some script if you use
the same software in the same script you
should be able to get the same
conclusion if you also have the same
data so it's an issue of performing a
reanalysis or what kind of repeating and
getting the same result out of the same
package sometimes it may not be exactly
the same result so for example if you
have a permutation procedure and you run
it two different times you may not get
exactly the same result but but if the
result is substantially different then
you should start to worry about
something not being exactly what you
thought it should be reproducibility of
result is something that usually we use
a timer application which means that
we're performing a new study we are
collecting new data new observations new
participants new whatever and we want to
produce corroborating result in that new
experiment having followed the same
observational or experimental method as
we did in the original study so people
will talk about exact replication when
they tried to do exactly the same thing
obviously it's never possible to do
exactly the same thing there will always
be some deviation from what was done in
the first study minor or major sometimes
and therefore this leads to a potential
for debate and this leads to
reproducibility of inferences which is
the making of knowledge claims of
similar strength from a study
replication or from multiple studies or
from a body of evidence different people
see the same results and they reach
different conclusions on what these mean
because of different backgrounds
different conflicts of interest
different beliefs different priors or or
different understanding on what the
results mean there's differences across
scientific field that affect also what
we mean by reproducible research it's
not the same in sociology in physics in
medicine
by informatics there's a great variance
in the degree of determinism that these
fields have the signal to measurement
error ratio can be substantially
different the complexity of the designs
and the measurement tools can also vary
a lot the closeness of fit that we are
seeking between the hypothesis the
experimental design and data may also be
different the statistical and analytical
methods that are used as offices that
some of them get entrenched within
specific kinds of infinity of
experimental results may vary
usually it's higher in social science
disciplines and in biomedical
disciplines and higher in biomedical
disciplines compared to physical
sciences well if there is even a culture
of replication transparency and
simulating knowledge some fields are
very open and they're sharing software
code data protocols as a cynic one on
others don't share much or anything some
fields are willing to perform
replications and they feel that unless
they do that it's not going to be
believable no matter what they come up
with and other fields the replication as
a me-too waste of time the statistical
criteria of truth claims and very
substantially many fields in biomedicine
are stuck with p-values less than 0.05
being enough to claim a discovery or
some sort of finding while in omics
p-values of 10 to the minus 8 are sought
pretty much routine e some fields there
are completely abandoning p-values or
using false discovery rate sorbets
factors and some fields are in
transition using different modalities
that sometimes reach different
confusions when it comes to
reproducibility of inferences finally
there's differences to the purposes to
which findings will be put in the
consequences of false conclusions so
some scientific findings may be
interested in some very fancy
mechanistic
view of of life or some phenomena and
this may have very little repercussion
for life and death but other studies
that may make input into recommendations
that effect the treatment of millions of
people and obviously their outcomes
including life and death this is a map
of 20 million papers published in the
last 15 years it also includes 2 million
patents and it's an effort to see how
many solar systems exist in this galaxy
of science there's about 200,000 solar
systems of different scientific
disciplines and the different colors
highlight the 13 big clusters so life
sciences is one such and physics is
another but if you look closely there's
200,000 disciplines and each one of them
may have its own rules of engagement in
its own understanding about what
reproducibility means and how exactly it
should be implemented so when you try to
cross the boundaries sometimes you you
see that fields that are seemingly doing
almost the same thing they have very
different standards about very produce
ability practices the common denominator
across almost all fields is that
everybody is trying to come up with a
significant result so this is an
evaluation of the entire pubmed where
the 15 million paper since 1990 that we
performed and published last year in
JAMA and we found that 96% of papers
that use p-values and their abstracts
they claim significant results
participative significant results
looking at about a million full-text
papers in PMC full-text again 96% of
them claim significant result and the
vast majority of them say that they're
novel so if you take that literally
scientific discovery has become a boring
nuisance it's just so much of it that we
don't really know what to make of it so
reproducibility is probably our best
chance at the moment to filter out how
many of these millions of claims are
real true and potentially translatable
to something that could help people
eventually now in the current
environment this may not be easy because
the typical recipe of research practices
in most biomedical fields is that you
have the prototype of a principal
investigator who is so low and siloed
unavoidably this means that he or she
will be using mostly studies of small
sample size would be cherry picking one
or the best hypothesis to try to get to
significant results because this is the
way to then seek funding there's a lot
of post hoc analysis being done a
p-value of 0.05 or slightly less is
enough as I said before there's no
registration of the ideas or the product
cause very little data sharing and no
replication because replication only has
a chance of refuting or not replicating
something that is already statistically
significant so people think why should I
waste my time to kill all the work that
I did and then not be able to publish it
in a high-profile journal so this is a a
setting of incentives that don't really
aligned with reproducible science and
this is what you get when you have a
field performing in that fashion this is
looking at about 1,800 data sets of fMRI
studies and I have plotted for you the
number of false eyes that have been
discovered as a function of the sample
size the only way to discover a lot of
both eye for different phenotypes or
features or tasks is to perform very
small studies when we perform larger
studies these posts I go away where the
effects become much smaller most of
those disappear and it's very likely
that most of these claim discoveries in
very small studies don't really mean
much this is not just happening in the
fMRI research a couple years ago we
looked across very different fields
across neuroscience ranging from early
basic research preclinical research
clinical research clinical trials and
the common denominator was power failure
we had a paradigm of having very small
sample size studies
you expect to have major problems with
their reproducibility this is another
exercise looking at neuroscience
psychology and medical psychology and
psychiatry literature where we did some
in depth text mining of these studies
and the the common denominator even
though there is quite some variability
across different subfields and journals
is that they have very small sample
sizes which are likely to lead to
inflated effect sizes and very often
false positive effect sizes which you
need some replication effort to try to
see whether they stand the test of
replication this is a completely
different field this is economics along
with the film Stanley and crystal yogurt
we've looked at every single
meta-analysis that we could identify in
economics this is mostly observational
economics as opposed to experimental
economics we found 130 topics more than
10,000 studies and more than 70,000
effect estimates the common denominator
is again very small very limited power
for the majority of these studies and
these topics show you you expect to see
a similar performance of observational
economics and observational neuroscience
even though these two disciplines are so
far apart there's some fields where we
do have the benefit of having performed
replications in very large scale and one
such field is genetic epidemiology
because in genetic epidemiology the cost
of performing replications has been very
low it's very easy and very cheap to
genotype very large sample sizes and
this is in contrast to what is happening
in many other fields were running the
experiments continues to be very
expensive so in genetics we could go
back when we moved into the genome-wide
Association era and test what we had
discovered in the candid in era when we
were performing research with small
studies one gene at the time one
hypothesis the time or a few hypotheses
of time the replication rate was one
point two percent so of all these
several tens of thousands of papers that
have been published in the candid gene
era about associations of single gene
sets began
single phenotypes only 1.2 percent were
validated when they were tested with
very large sample sizes with very
accurate and large-scale genome-wide
Association studies preclinical research
has also seen a flurry of results that
are not looking very nice in terms of
very participate a series of
investigations mostly run by the
industry have shown reproducibility
rates ranging from 0 percent to 25
percent the reason that the industry has
led these efforts is that they do want
to use preclinical research to try to
develop new drug targets so they use
these leads from papers that have been
published by the best investigators in
academia in the best centers the best
research institutes and they want to
make sense of them and translate them
into new drugs or new diagnostics and it
doesn't work so when they did that in
large scale 30 25 % of these
high-profile papers could be reproduced
so Glenn Begley wrote in nature in 2012
that the failure to win the war in
cancer has been blamed on many factors
but recently a new culprit has emerged
too many basic scientific discoveries
are wrong and that was his conclusion
when his team was able to reproduce only
6 of 53 landmark studies for Amgen
oncology drug target projects now what
does it mean to replicate or to
reproduce this can be contested
obviously and we don't really know on
whether we have the right answer when we
have an original study or when we have a
replication reproduction effort that
disagrees in one way or another versus
the original study it's possible that
the original study may be correct and
the reproducibility effort may be wrong
it could be that both are correct but
they were not really exact replicas of
each other or it could be that both of
them are actually wrong and there's some
common biases that they had so
regardless of whether they agree or they
disagree they could still be wrong but
at a minimum when we have large number
years of studies we can start talking
about patterns of reproducibility across
different fields
even though single cases will be heavily
debated and this is what they call the
reproducibility war so pretty recently
the first results of the Reapers ability
project the cancer biology were released
and every single of these
reproducibility efforts was heavily
contested so here's one example where
the results look very nice you have an
effect in the original study that is
significant you have an effect in the
replication effort the meta-analysis
also shows in effect the effect size is
slightly less in the reproducibility but
that's okay but depending on whether you
adjust for example for multiplicity of
analysis then the result in the
reproducibility may no longer be
statistically significant so one might
say that we have powered the
reproducibility to be significant and
now it is not but if you don't correct
for multiplicity comparison which is
also fair because this is very
participatory effort then it is
significant this this led to a huge
debate even though I don't really see
much debate there's these results seem
to be pretty consistent with each other
here's another example where things are
clearly very different I mean you see
that if you take panel a the effect size
but also the confidence intervals are
very different in the original study and
the reproducibility estimate you have a
glass Delta 7.41 versus a minus 0.32 and
with pretty high confidence intervals
again this can lead to a lot of debate
and there's lots of things at stake here
there's it's not just the veracity of
the results but it's also whatever other
investment has been made into trying to
develop the original study into some
translational application for example
whether new studies have been launched
whether clinical trials are being
planned based on these results whether
there's investment whether enterpreneurs
or venture capitalists are thinking
about giving money to invest in that
original observation that now seems to
be so squarely refuted
these concerns have been raised
increasingly in a number of fields
here's a partial list showing
reproducibility concerns in preclinical
studies on microarray data on stroke
animal studies general biology oncology
genome sequencing mouse and vivo studies
neurological studies mouse models
genomic cell line analysis microarray
data commercial antibodies and eliza's
and the way that journals handle
information also and they pertain to
disciplines as different as near science
from ecology genomics by informatics
stem cell biology and college in vitro
testing chemistry led discovery
computational biology pathology
biomarkers organizational psychology and
observational research of all sorts so
my field if I had to pick one out of
many where I have failed is probably
academi ology and you can see here that
the 0 out of 52 hypotheses that were
claimed in major epidemiological studies
were subsequently confirmed in
randomised trials this is a nice paper
by Stan Yangon and Carr a few years ago
this is one of the most famous recent
reproducibility attempts it's the open
science collaboration effort where 270
investigators and their teams try to
reproduce a hundred experiments
published in the top psychology journals
and the results clearly don't look very
nice you can see the comparison of
p-values and effect sizes in the
original studies in the replications
about a third of the influential papers
could be reproduced depending on on how
exactly you define reproducibility you
may have a little bit of a different
answer but but clearly they seem to be
different and even when they could be
reproduced the effect sizes typically
were much smaller in the replications
compared to the original studies this
has led to a reproducibility war so
there were technical comments and
replies in science two months after the
publication of that very influential
study and some top psychologists felt
that there's nothing wrong
this is the way that it should be and
actually the reproducibility effort is
wrong is is not what it should be and
there's many reasons and there were
examples being pursued as really not
being the best effort to replicate the
original finding however one would
wonder if you have the situation where
you have 270 investigators in their
teams from the best institutions joining
forces performing something with with
the best possible methods with perfect
transparency with everything being
reviewed at all stages by the best gears
if this is found or claimed to be so
wrong and so suboptimal what would one
think about other studies that really
don't have the benefit of that
cumulative wisdom and expertise being in
in them here's another example this is
the experimental economics they have
also tried to do their reproducibility
checks and their reproducibility results
seem a bit better about a third of the
studies could not be reproduced it's a
small sample it's only 18 papers that
have been published in major economics
journals but it seems a bit better
compared to what has been documented in
preclinical research in biomedicine and
in psychology now the difference could
be just due to chance
but it could also be due to the fact
that the experimental economics for a
number of years now has followed a
number of policies that we think both
based on theory and on some empirical
data that should lead to better
reproducibility so they do have
protocols that are communicated they do
share all the software and the code and
all the thorough data with other
scientists and this is also prerequisite
for publication so we have a culture
where there's openness and transparency
and a lot of thought goes into
developing protocols plus you have a
culture where you have experimental
results where you expect to see better
reproducibility compared to just
observational data set especially
observational data says that
sometimes are not even conceived with a
particular purpose of looking at the one
specific question that then gets
published
here's another side of the
reproducibility debate sometimes that
effect sizes may not completely
nullified upon replication efforts but
they may become much smaller and this is
a one classic example where we see this
in biomarker study if you plot the
relative risk in the highly cited study
that typically has been one of the first
ones or the first one about a biomarker
and the relative risk in the larger
study all the action is below the
diagonal with just a couple of
exceptions which means that the largest
study finds much smaller effect sizes
they're not null so they're not relative
risks of one but they're much smaller
compared to what the original study had
found so that biomarker still has some
ability to discriminate or predict but
not as much
far less compared to what the original
highly cited study would have suggested
another dimension as I mentioned before
is reanalysis or repeatability in
reanalysis we're not performing a new
study we're just going back and
reexamining the data from a study that
has been done published and now
everybody can scrutinize because the
road data are available so there's some
experience of repeatability checks and
one of them is an effort that we did
jointly with Nature Genetics a number of
years ago Nature Genetics was one of the
first journals that made the
availability of software protocols and
row data a prerequisite for publication
for microarray studies and when we did
that exercise looking at 18 papers that
had been published in Nature Genetics we
could not reproduce more than two of the
18 papers some could be reproduced with
discrepancies or with discrepancies from
processed data or partially but most
could not be reproduced at all and the
reason for the non reproduction was that
the data were not available the software
was homemade and had disappeared the
methods were unclear so we had several
teams of micro
analysts around the world he couldn't
understand exactly what was being done
in that paper or the result was
different even though everything was
available and methods were very clear
and the data we're there and the
software could be made to work the
result was not what had been published
in the original paper so this is
probably this quieting because we're
talking about the best field in genetics
and one of the best in science at large
and the most transparent field at that
time with avant-garde ideas about
sharing of information and software and
methods
here's another field where there have
been some experience on we're now at
this randomized clinical trial data have
mostly not been available to other
investigators but this is changing in
the past it was very difficult to get
these data but currently there's about
20,000 clinical trials worth of data
that you can get hold of one way or
another not necessarily completely free
access but at least you can apply for
getting them and hopefully you can get
them in the past there were very very
few such trials and we found 37
reanalysis that had examined the very
same question as the original trial in
the very same data and we found that 35%
of the time the reanalysis reached an
entirely different conclusion compared
to the original paper so the original
paper would have claimed that the
patient should be treated and the
reanalysis would say no they should not
be treated or the type of patients to be
treated would be different in the
original paper versus the reanalysis one
might thing that this might be some
enemies of the original investigators
who are trying to put them to shame but
actually almost always the original
authors were involved also as co-authors
in the reanalysis which means that what
we have documented here is likely to be
just the tip of the iceberg probably
many many more reanalysis of randomised
trials were done possibly in the
hundreds or even thousands but a key
attractor for disseminating and
publishing the results of area
has been the ability to say that I found
something new so even though it is the
same author's having found something new
and reaching a different conclusion
might have been an incentive to publish
which makes things very confusing but
this is the way that the publication
system operates apparently there is also
an opposite movement moving in the
opposite direction of reproducibility
and transparency that would facilitate
the reproducibility checks and
reanalysis I call this stealth research
which means that some organizations and
some entities feel that nothing should
be shared nothing should be communicated
information should be kept as trade
secret there's no need to try to
replicate rule just do things internally
we will make sure that they're fine and
then we will conquer the world and this
is pretty much the example upon which
farah naaz was was built so when I wrote
that paper in JAMA two and a half years
ago thoroughness I had published about a
hundred patents but practically nothing
in the peer-reviewed literature about
it's a disruptive innovative method so I
question whether this lack of
transparency which does not allow anyone
to replicate what they do and reproduce
what they do is the way to move forward
and at that time they were really very
powerful but within a few months after
that after an investigation by Wall
Street Journal and scrutiny by federal
regulators and other entities the
company imploded so stealth research
didn't seem to be such a good idea after
all some potential solutions to improve
reproducibility
there's many such solutions and I have
discussed some of them already as I was
going through these examples some of
them we know that they would work very
well others are very speculative and we
need empirical evidence as to their
efficacy there are some solutions that
may sound nice but they could cost a lot
they could mean that we need to invest a
lot of effort and and therefore maybe
the trade-offs are not such that we
would recommend them for example one
solution might be to
replicate everything just keep on
replicating every single item that you
see produced in science or publishing in
the scientific literature probably not a
very good investment that would mean
that we would need to either double the
research budget or somehow cut our
investment in half in terms of what new
ideas we can pursue or another such idea
that I think is highly suspect is try to
audit everything that is being done and
this means that I would need to clone
myself and everybody would need to clone
themselves so that they have the
scientists and the auditor scientists
following as their shadow wherever they
go in the lab or in their computer to to
try to reanalyze and reproduce
everything that they do clearly we
cannot do that
however there's many things that we
could do and here's a few examples that
belong to 12 families of reproducibility
efforts that may improve the veracity
and the truthfulness and trustworthiness
of the results that we get one option is
to promote replication culture at large
so embed replication in the discovery
phase this is what has happened in
genetic epidemiology people don't really
separate that much discovery from
replication because they understand that
replication is part of the discovery so
that this is a one out of zillions of
Manhattan plots that you will see in
that literature in the past we thought
that we had discovered millions of the
genes that could affect smoking behavior
and this is what these Manhattan plots
are about in in the candle gene era
there were 359 genes that had been
discovered as being associated with
smoking behavior when we performed
large-scale studies where we had the
multiple teams replicating each other's
findings and joining all their data
instead of just publishing them one
piece at a time
we could only validate one of these 359
and we came up with another dozen or so
it's better to have a dozen that we
very certain that their true rather than
a 359 that are completely spurious if we
do replication it needs to be
inexpensive and easy to do and then who
is going to do it
is it going to be the same investigators
this is going to be different
investigators of the same school it is
going to be different investigators of
competing theories and hypotheses do we
need combinations of the above in some
easy to do problems maybe we can open
replication to the white public so lots
of mathematics questions they can be
split into tens of thousands of
computers and people could run them in
their own desktop or laptop and then
accumulate that information at some
central facility these are questions
that cannot be answered in a generic
term they need to be seen on a
case-by-case basis I think that there
are some general patterns that if you
have the same investigators trying to
replicate you and avoid ibly have some
Allegiance bias the same applies if you
have investigators of the same school so
one has to ask how strong is allegiance
by it likely to be do we have
experimental constraints and safeguards
that would alleviate the concern for
except for such Allegiance bias and if
not then we probably need to think of
different investigators who try to test
whether the original experiments were
correct and the inferences were valid
registration is an other possibility and
this means that if I do have a
hypothesis and a protocol I would like
to register it upfront so that people
would know that this is what I do and
there would be full transparency about
all the steps that I have followed so
that people would compare notes with
what was the original intention and they
could also try to reproduce what was
done at the first place this is not
always possible there's a lot of
research that I call level zero research
blue sky science there can be no
registration there because really no one
has a preconceived deliverable or
hypothesis in mind people are just
like crazy very different things and if
something pans out they will report it
the only thing that I want in that case
is sound transparency that this is how
this emerged that it was completely
unrestricted exploratory blue sky
science and there was no plan this is
what I got now we need some replication
effort but we can really claim that
there was any specific hypothesis or
protocol that was preset level one would
be a registration of a data set which
means that I can share information on
how many observational data sets I have
available people would know what the
spectrum of multiplicity is in these
data sets so when they see a published
analysis about one risk factor with one
outcome they can immediately tell that
that was from a data set that includes
five million variables for a data set
that includes five variables that that
makes a huge difference because if I
have published that analysis with a
p-value of 0.05 nine from a database
that includes five million variables
then people might easily question
whether that p-value is really valid
then unless I have pre-registered that
it's very hard to believe that I
disclose my eyes and could not analyze
anything else other than that
Association level 2 would be
registration of the protocol and that
means that there is a protocol level 3
is registration of the analysis plan and
that means that there is an announced
plan very often there is a protocol but
there's no statistical analysis plan and
this is decided at a late stage after
the data have been collected and
sometimes even after some analysis has
been done which creates some shade of
gray into the credibility of the
research but sometimes some of that
ambiguity may be
unavoidably true because things don't
happen the way that they were intended
during the conduct of the study
especially in the study with long term
follow-up and with lots of unpredictable
features that may emerge during its
contact level for his registration of
analysis plan and raw data which means
that I also provide the detailed
information that I have collected for
others to
analyze repeat and also compare notes if
they try to reproduce in a replication
study and level-5 is open live streaming
where every day in the morning I just
put online what are the experiments and
what are the analysis that I'm planning
to do for the rest of the day or I can
do that overnight I can get feedback
from the whole scientific community on
whether this is a good idea on whether I
could improve any of that and then I
revisit the analysis or the experimental
plan and I report the results and then I
put my new set of experiments in line
and everybody can comment in a
continuing basis this is one example of
a registered report it's part of the
reproducibility project cancer biology
in a way these papers have been
published before the research was done
it's the detailed product all of what
will be done practically it can all also
convey what are the tables and the
figures that will be in the final paper
when the results get accumulated so
everybody can see that this is the
original intention and then can compare
notes on whether the original intention
was followed and the paper is populated
with the results and published but
there's full correspondence between the
registered report before the research is
done and the registered report after the
research is done that's some empirical
data here on the public availability of
research data in high impact factor
journals these are the journals that
have the highest impact factor across
all science and who published primary
research and if you see that green color
that's good news it means that their
policy the datoria policies in place for
sharing information and for making also
information available on request
including protocols and also making this
a condition of publication and lots of
color means that there are these
policies in place
but the last column shows how many out
of ten of these papers actually adhere
to these policies in each one of these
journals and there are lots of zeros
there which means that the policies are
in place but really implementing them is
not easy so very often many journals say
do make your data available we encourage
you to do that but actually this does
not happen it's not easy to share data
and many fields have taken the steps to
make that easy and common and widespread
but others who have less experience
probably see as an obstacle that is very
difficult to surmount and there's always
these open questions about who will
prepare these data to make them
meaningfully available not just throw
them out and then people would be
confused and probably we would get a lot
of confusing wee analysis or
reproducibility checks then how quickly
should the data become available is
there some sort of enforcement that can
be implemented that it should there be
some committee or some some way to sort
out whether everybody or some particular
people with particular ideas should be
able to access these data how quickly
should the data become available within
six months within one year many projects
are really finished and they can be
goldmines to continue to exploit with
further analysis empirically sharing
does not happen often this is some data
covering the period from 2000 to 2014 we
took a random sample of the entire
PubMed and we could see that out of the
500 papers about half of them included
primary data but of these 250 only one
of them had a full Prodigal that has
been published and this was a separate
publication and none of them had all the
raw data available for everyone to use
with no restrictions so even though
there's a lot of discussion and even
though there are fields
I do have data sharing in place most of
the time this does not happen across the
broader biomedical literature there's
many efforts to try to enhance and
support and reward some of the practices
that are likely to lead to better
reproducibility so once that system is
the badge system that has been
implemented in the Open Science
framework in several journals in
psychology mostly but also beyond
psychology have started adopting this
and basically the papers can get badges
for openness for having a protocol for
having pre-register protocol for having
raw data available and you can see here
that psychological science journal that
adopted that policy had a steep increase
in the percentage of articles that were
reporting available data for other
investigators to use but obviously we
don't know what's happening in other
journals and whether people who do want
to have these open and transparent and
sharing policies eventually cluster
towards the journals that reward these
policies and make the other journals
even more poor in terms of
reproducibility prerequisites there's a
lot of debate about how to enhance
reproducibility for computational
methods a few months ago we published a
set of guidelines for reproducibility
aspects that involve data code and
workflows and the way that we can see
that is a set of different levels of
reproducibility so ideally you would
like to have everything available and
also make sure that someone has checked
every single step of what is being
published but realistically this may not
be possible because then you need to
have the power and the workforce to be
able to go through everything and repeat
everything that has been done therefore
you can consider different levels and
the lower level would be that someone
would at least check that the links
where the data are supposed to be where
the software is supposed to be where the
script is supposed to be these links
functional and and you can get things to
move now whether you get exactly the
same results that would take things to a
different level that would require more
effort and more time and more commitment
better statistics and methods clearly
can improve very per disability record
as I mentioned earlier we can think of
improving the transparency of
availability of analysis plans currently
very few studies have their analysis
plans visible before they're done I
think that there is plenty of room to
improve statistical training and
literacy and numeracy of the scientific
workforce at all levels starting at a
very early age better study design some
standard features that will promote the
trustworthiness of the results for
example randomization and blinding of
investigators and animal experiments are
very easy to do but they're not done and
finally some checklists that
investigators in each field would agree
they are totally essential to improve
the chances of the research being
reproducible these are data from in vivo
studies mostly on animals and you see
that the vast majority of them don't use
blinding for assessing outcomes and they
don't use randomization even though that
would cost nothing and would clearly
enhance the chances of the research
being reproducible institutional
practices can also improve
reproducibility students postdoc fellows
investigators can be trained on
practices that improve the chances of
their research being reproducible and
you can see that as some sort of
continuous methodological training
actually we teach our students and our
fellows and investigators mostly about
subject matter details but less so about
the core of experimental methods of
experimental design and safeguards that
would promote the reproducibility of of
what they do and also institutions can
have institution wide policy that would
producible practices and maybe penalize
and practices that are clearly against
the needs of reproducibility reporting
standards can go quite a long way in
improving transparency about what has
been done there's about 300 reporting
standards that you can find in the
equator website and each one of them
pertain
- one type of study design or setting
many people argue that even though this
is helpful it is a bit late because once
you have a study that has been done just
reporting what was done and sometimes
what was done might have been suboptimal
even foolish may not be so helpful and
it's also asking people to accept that
of what I did was completely foolish so
there's a new wave of such guidance that
is focusing on protocols rather than
finished studies and you can also find
an equator and number of such efforts
that focus on what do we need to build a
good product or for an next type of
design rather than just a way to report
a study that has already been completed
finally we need empirical research on
how to fix some of these reproducibility
problems so our metric Center at
Stanford is really trying to put
together efforts that are focused around
improving research practices and
eventually getting more reproducible
research this covers issues of methods
of reporting of verification or
reproducibility per se of evaluation and
of rewards because all of these are
interconnected in some way or another
and there's many initiatives around the
world currently that are focusing on
various aspects of that reproducibility
puzzle so there's more appearing almost
on a weekly basis and very often we see
that there is some overlap in these
initiatives some redundancy but some not
necessarily bad redundancy because I
think that we need more efforts in this
sphere but also some need of
coordination of all these efforts that
are happening across very different
disciplines and across different
countries and across different settings
so at the end of the day maybe to really
improve reproducibility we need to make
it to have meaning in the very word
system so we need to find ways to
re-engineer our reward system which is
focus mostly on productivity and
I think that productivity is very nice
they have nothing against productivity
it's very good for people to be
productive and published and get support
for their work and publish more and so
forth but this needs to be tied also
with the quality reproducibility sharing
and translational impact of the research
so I use that acronym of pqrst sounds
like an electrocardiogram and currently
we're focusing too much on the p-wave
well we need to find ways to reward
these other dimensions that would
increase the trustworthiness of what is
being produced scientists do want to see
that done there's several surveys that
suggest that we do care about
reproducibility and the scientific
community is not just trying to publish
and run away we do want to get things
right eventually it would be nice to be
right at the first place but sometimes
we know that this is not going to happen
and science makes progress through
correcting itself we all do care though
about getting things right eventually
and having reproducible results that we
can trust and also apply I will end with
a recent paper that is I think a good
piece of reading material and the
manifesto for reproducible science that
we published three months ago in nature
human behavior it's a coalition of
scientists coming from very different
fields but feeling that there are some
common threats and common opportunities
around reproducibility in that circle of
generating in studying hypothesis
designing studies conducting Studies
collecting data analyzing data testing
hypothesis and troubling results
publishing and then conducting the next
experiments so forth there are these
threats that we can deal with with
reproducible practices and these
practices would depend on different
stakeholders sometimes scientists can
make a difference
other types other times it would be
journals that need to take the lead
funders can be very influential
institutions can have their share and
obviously the more stakeholders you have
in the game in favor of reproducible
research the more like
it is that you would get the results
that you want all of these stakeholders
involved in science have sometimes very
different types of interest in research
some of them want to see results being
published so they want publishable
research others want fundable research
some want to see things work
translatable research and some want to
make profit there's nothing wrong with
any of these four ideas about what
research should do for us but we need to
coordinate our efforts and to help these
stakeholders align so that the research
eventually would be reproducible to
conclude reproducibility has different
meanings across different scientific
disciplines but eventually all of them
aim at enhancing our trust in scientific
findings there's many possible
interventions that may improve the
efficiency of research practices and the
reproducibility of the scientific
literature we know that some of them
work that we have very little evidence
about many others so empirical meta
research would be useful not only to
assess the prevalence of problems of
reproducibility but also to assess the
effectiveness and the potential harms of
interventions that try to make research
more reproducible thank you thank you
John that was fantastic and I really
appreciate your coming this morning we
already have a million questions well at
least a dozen questions in the question
box those of you who want to pose
questions to John please type your
questions in there I will try to select
questions that I think are going to be
easier to answer and I'll edit Oriole
eyes a little bit in the interest of
time so it's just not much much time
left this morning
our first question in the question box
says many of my colleague
scientist state that these claims of
unreproducible 'ti are overblown they
often say that we know who does poor
work and we know who does good work and
yen science is self-correcting so so we
should we not overreact that by shaking
the system we could do much more damage
to the scientific process or enterprise
which is so good for society what is
your response
I guess the corollary question is how do
we know that most
research papers are not false so I think
that meta research papers have their own
share of reproducibility no doubt but I
think that the reproducibility is at the
core of the scientific method so it's
not really something new I think that
science has always made progress because
it's focusing on better methods better
scrutiny better ability to correct
itself so I don't see that as a new
message that is disrupting science in a
way it is just supporting science and
and offering the the real value of
science which is exactly that it can
correct itself there's clearly vast
differences across different fields in
terms of how much lack of
reproducibility we see and also in terms
of what it means not to see a result
being reproduced I think that the
connotations are very different the
implications are very different but at
the end of the day any efforts to
correct a scientific record more
efficiently more quickly more rigorously
more robustly is only going to make the
science look better not worse there's
some school of thought that says that
well these are difficult times but you
know it has always been difficult time
for science unfortunately science is the
best thing that has happened to humans
that this is something that many people
don't realize so let's just forget about
this and just try to claim that science
knows everything and everything that we
publish is correct well this is a very
dangerous part because if we do that
there will be lots of cases that easily
some results will be shown to be
incorrect and then we are just giving
ammunition to our critics that we were
overconfident in results that we
shouldn't have been overconfident with
so I I do believe that to defend science
we need to defend the scientific method
not some conception of science as being
absolutely correct all the time which is
not what science is about okay ah one of
the listeners says that in fact we need
to go back to a poppers idea of the
scientific method where we don't
try to prove hypotheses which are which
is impossible to do but to eliminate
alternatives and it's unfair I think
that this is pretty much done already to
to a good extent and I think that
there's also that higher level of
integration of knowledge where indeed we
may be eliminating some hypotheses and
making others more likely I would prefer
to see things in a Bayesian view and
think of the cumulative evidence kind of
affecting our priors and generating some
posterior there are some posters that
are extremely strong and I will not be
convinced otherwise and unless there's
amazingly extraordinary evidence to the
contrary so you know climate change or
tobacco killing people or MMR is safe
that I can't think of what evidence
would persuade me that you know these
statements are not correct many other
statements they just have some modest or
high or low credibility and they have
some alternatives that also have modest
low or or high credibility and as we
accumulate more data we can fine-tune
where our beliefs emerge and and
sometimes we need to act based on
relatively modest credibility and and we
don't need to wait until we know
something 100% to be sure and until we
have eliminated every other alternative
because what is at stake may require
immediate action even even in the face
of uncertainty so that but I think if we
see things from that perspective
it makes sense that we can have a
gradient of certainty and uncertainty
for different types of scientific
findings hypotheses and their
alternatives to any thoughts on how we
can apply analysis of reproducibility to
studies that involve clinical data I
guess particularly EHR data that are
collected opportune
mystically not as part of a specific
protocol or HIPAA may interfere with our
ability to make data public I think that
there's many opportunities for
reproducibility in in this sphere
clearly EHR data have their own
peculiarities but in essence there's
many datasets many databases that depend
on EHR and some of them may have been
compatibilities against each other but
there is also some cross talk
opportunities so there are opportunities
to compare notes across EHR platforms
and data and analysis and in many
opportunities in many situations there
may be opportunities also to compare
notes of some of the entrances made from
EHR data against other traditional types
of designs including in some cases even
randomized control trials that may have
addressed a similar question so I think
that this is a space where you could
think of a pretty robust reproducibility
agenda and try to map the performance of
these data sets in comparisons within
themselves between themselves and in
comparison with other methods of making
inference of these effects I will share
notes that you talked about
reproducibility and the biomedical and
behavioral sciences what can you tell us
about physical sciences or chemical
sciences so there's also work done on
reproducibility and related teams in the
physical sciences probably less compared
to social sciences and biomedical
sciences but but but we do have several
pieces of evidence is that the general
perception is that physics and chemistry
have higher reproducibility and to a
large extent this is true there's some
simple reasons for that usually there is
a stronger experimental design there is
more determinism in in their data they
have a stronger history of transparency
and sharing so example everything in
high energy and particle physics
practically shared with
large community of tens of thousands of
physicists who can look at the data and
eventually they all publish their
results together they have very
stringent statistical rules for claiming
discoveries so they have a 5 Sigma rule
that is equivalent to a p-value of 10 to
the minus 7 which is very close to the
genome wide level of significance that
is used in biomedicine that has worked
pretty well in in genetic Association
studies for example so there's many
reasons why you see a pretty good
reproducibility in these Sciences
there's also great tolerance for
negative results most of the results in
experimental physics are negative
practically and nobody where is about
that you know the you see all these
papers coming out from CERN hundreds of
papers they have found one Higgs boson
and pretty much nothing else there was a
great discovery but I would say it's an
equally great discovery that all the
other results are negative and people
just say that this is what they are
there are still some problems in
specific fields that the experimentation
or the observation is more difficult for
example claims for exoplanets about 50%
of the time they turn out to be non
reproducible range from 25% to 60% in
different surveys some of the more
recent wave of chemical syntheses have
been a bit difficult to reproduce
independent labs but I hope that this is
the exception
so no scientific field is immune to this
problems because these are not
necessarily problems this is the
scientific method and you know and it's
difficult to do good science that's
great and on that note that we should we
should end this reached the end of the
hour John let me thank you for was a
really stimulating talk and well let me
thank all the people who dialed in this
morning was really great to hear you
thanks again thank you